it is 6 36 on your Tuesday morning and
new check it out reliving the legend of
Liberace boy he was flashy wasn't he the
flamboyant pianist was a Las Vegas
staple and now you can take a peek at
his past inside the Nevada State Museum
Candace Charles is live inside the
museum with a look showing us around
this morning Candace show us more
well there's a lot to see Sherry and
Nate I thought you guys might like it
good morning to you good morning folks
this is one of the big pieces that
caught my eye as soon as I walked in but
I gotta tell you like Liberace was so
much more than his wonderful beautiful
costumes and you can see that in the
pieces that were selected by the
wonderful curator Joseph Diaz thank you
so much for joining us this morning
let's get to the costumes so tell me a
little bit about these pieces absolutely
so this is just a handful of the many
costumes that Liberace had some of more
iconic pieces I do love this piece
called the Faberge cape and a suit and
he would often emerge out of a giant
Pink Faberge Egg during what a story yes
absolutely that's amazing and even the
shoes are embellished
wonderful so many people as well with
all of his clothing and I think it looks
like a lot of the Liberace talk a little
bit about that absolutely oftentimes you
have to go through several institutions
to borrow but we were fortunate enough
to borrow most of the pieces from the
Liberace Foundation here in Las Vegas
amazing and as I mentioned he had a lot
of different influences on a lot of
different artists but also a lot of
different communities this wonderful
orange wall here really is that tell me
a little bit about that yeah absolutely
he um often would encourage
up-and-coming African-American artists
here in Las Vegas during a time where it
wasn't really
it was frowned upon and then he also
encouraged a lot of gay performers
inspired them such as Elton John
absolutely we see we seals influences
today still
together this is quite a beautiful space
we appreciate it thank you and of course
you guys
you got to sell yourself all the way
until December 31st so quite some time
we got to cover with these Hills about
admission
you'll need to know to come on down but
for now live from the Nevada State
Museum in Las Vegas at the Springs
Preserve I'm Candace Charles 8 news now
I have to say I love the Sparkles and
the feathers and all that yeah and I
think they're trying to bring the
Liberace Mansion uh back it had closed
once again so I think there's another
Liberace part of history back in the
valley well yeah they need more High
School seniors to do their proms there
like you did it wasn't my choice but it
was fun very cool